truth okay if i know things about the
world or i wouldn't turn a book
not necessarily nice things
the eighth episode of succession's third
season chianti shower is all about
confronting the truth it may sound like
the most simple source of conflict two
characters sit down and reveal the truth
to one another but for succession
despite the roy family running a media
empire the truth is something hard to
come by with so many ulterior motives
power differentials and appearances to
maintain the characters exist within a
web of lies
for logan's children people avoid
telling them the truth resulting in them
never truly facing the consequences of
their actions so they're protected from
all the dangers of the outside world at
the cost of enduring the torture of
their father or as marsha put it in
season 1 he made you a playground and
you think it's the whole world
everyone is so used to lying and
deceiving in order to achieve their next
goal that they don't seem to really know
what the truth is anymore but this
episode maintained the truth as a
punishing theme for each character
making it one of the most powerful
episodes of the entire series so far and
it happened over six masterfully written
scenes
the first scene that establishes this
theme is when grey gets a lot of kudos
from shave and tom for managing to date
comfrey someone he has pursued as a goal
for several episodes
however greg already feels that their
dynamic is missing something i do wonder
is there
depth there like is i don't know is
there substance
gregg's more romantic view of dating is
mocked and dismissed by shivan tom who
instead view this as a good dating
strategy for greg to get on the date
ladder
this shows the key difference in how the
roy family views people versus how a
normal person does
greg isn't fully indoctrinated to this
mindset yet so he doesn't want something
fake when he initially pursued comfrey
it was out of genuine optimism but it
feels stale in practice because of her
potential ulterior motives
maybe i wonder when she gets to know the
quote unquote real me
will she stick around
having witnessed how empty and unhappy
fake relationships around him appear to
be greg actually wants to ask the tough
questions that the other family members
avoid such as does she really like me
and the answer to that question could be
painful but it seems that the truth is
of no concern to shave or tom yet
in the second moment of truth conor
proposes to his girlfriend willa not
because he wants to marry her but
because it's a good strategy in case he
runs for president
will you make me
the most happiest man slash most
bulletproof candidate
he doesn't even claim it was his idea
but his campaign managers making the
whole proposal empty and fake he could
have just proposed to her and let it
feel real but instead this scene
showcases that conor views her as
nothing more than a political prop
someone that's only part of his game to
gain more power and his smile is
oblivious as to what's so unromantic and
disingenuous about the proposal
similar to greg willa has reservations
about being part of something empty and
exclusively for appearances the truth is
that conor doesn't really want to marry
her he just thinks he might need to in
order to win when she shows reluctance
conor doesn't seem to feel any hurt
because he isn't emotionally invested in
her true feelings but he feels concerned
about how this looks
so he's actually happy as long as
everyone else perceives them to be in
love and engaged not for it to actually
be real
having set the table of some characters
not wanting something fake the rest of
the conflict in this episode grants them
that wish exposing the raw truth beneath
the surface
the family fly out to italy to their
mother's wedding despite not wanting to
go shiv attends for appearance sakes
something that always shines through in
succession's writing is how even the
most intimate of dynamics like mother
and daughter becomes tainted with
business talk as one by one they all try
to convince their mother to get a prenup
as protecting the wealth always comes
first they quickly devolve into
disagreement about who has contributed
more to their failing relationship
meaning they have to look back at why
she was such an absent figure in their
life she believes they chose to live
with logan even though she
simultaneously admits that she gave him
custody to protect their shares and you
knew how to twist the knife you knew
then and you know now
and i might cry
yeah where's the onion
shiv sees all of this as just
manipulatively playing the victim which
makes it easier for her to dismiss
everything she's saying but after this
small battle for who's a better or worse
person tossing around accusations like a
game of hot potato her mother reveals
something true and just notice how the
truth hits differently to business talk
or competition
truth is i probably should never have
had children
some people just aren't made to be
mothers
there's a quiet heartbreak in shiv's
face as if the truth just punched her in
the gut their dynamic always had this
undercurrent of bitterness but it was
more comfortable to not be able to
pinpoint why it's easier to bicker and
lie about who's really at fault than to
hear your own mother admit that she
regrets having you there's a noticeable
void inside of shiv and this
conversation just deepened it
she then twists the knife by saying she
wished she could have had dogs instead
but she couldn't because of logan
stating he never saw anything he loved
that he didn't want to kick it to see if
it would still come back there's
something incredibly raw about this
sentence especially coming from the
mother of these children the former wife
of logan roy it provides real insight
into how this family has been taught to
love
and this quote carries through to the
next scene where a combative shiv wants
to role-play with tom who tells her to
take the lead so she does but instead of
it being fun it's harsh and exposing
you're not good enough for me well let's
see about that yeah no i'm way out of
your league oh you think so yeah uh-huh
the acting of matthew mcfadden here is
incredible just the way he looks at her
he's searching for a way for it not to
be true for her to smile to laugh to
something but she doesn't
you love me
you
you can see he both means it and wants
to stop the game but has no alternative
other than to play along
even though i don't love you
but you want me anyway
[Music]
and now she twists the knife breaking
his heart with the truth the role play
is meant to be demeaning and dominating
but it's just hurtful because it's all
true he's always secretly suspected it
but now she's admitting it the question
greg was asking himself earlier
does she really like me is something tom
now has to grapple with when he chooses
to finally kiss her to end the scene
it's like a sad acceptance a submission
to her power and acknowledgement that
he'll always be beneath her
if we recall the quote from the last
scene we start to see how much shiv
actually resembles her father that maybe
she doesn't know how to love only to
test tom's limits and capacity for love
by kicking him away all the time to see
if he comes back which is painful for
the character and agonizing for the
audience because we know how sensitive
and in need of validation tom truly is
in the fifth scene kendall sits down
with his father to end their conflict
the scene starts with logan not even
trusting the food he's been served and
calls his grandson out to taste it first
this shows us that in order to get to
the truth logan will attack your
greatest weakness first this scene
between these two is one of the most
powerful in the series in an earlier
episode the power came from the silence
between them everything that was
unspoken but this time it's all about
what's finally willing to be said after
suspecting him of poisoning him kendall
asks his father who do you think i am
you think i want you dead i'll be broken
when you die but logan's response is
dismissive
he sees through the false sentiment this
scene is intended to be a confession
from kendall admitting that he's not who
he thought he was that he can't be his
father that he submits that he lost he
just wants the money that he was offered
in the last episode and he'll be gone
forever it's actually kendall being
honest with himself or so he thinks it's
important to establish that logan knows
the truth he sees the truth in people
who they really are what they really
want and why they will or won't get it
it's this core understanding of people
that allows him to bulldoze over them
exploiting their vices
this scene showcases the key difference
between their world views logan is
brutal harsh and dark life's not nights
on horseback it's a number on a piece of
paper it's a fight for a knife in the
mud
this killer instinct is what allowed him
to fight his way to the top whereas
kendall like marsha said in season one
was born into a playground his father
built for him
logan could almost respect kendall's
submission except that kendall then
reveals that he's given himself a
comforting narrative a safety blanket to
soften the blow of his failure you've
won
because you're corrupt and so is the
world i'm better than you you're kind of
evil
this turns into a similar dynamic
between shiv and her mother in the
previous scene where they bicker over
who's a better person but unlike their
mother logan won't hurt you by
confessing he's the bad guy he'll attack
your weakness the truth you're hiding
from yourself he wants you to drown in
the pain of your own failure so you'll
learn the lesson so he rejects kendall's
offer to quit for a payout confronts him
about the waiter he accidentally killed
and speculates some potential storylines
as to what he was even doing that night
were he and the waiter going off to
chase women or is he secretly gay or was
it just the drugs you can practically
see the news headlines he could pump out
bullying his full reign of power over
him i know who you are i know what you
want and i know your vices
then he strips kendo of the last thing
he has the story he's clinging to to
justify his failures
and whenever you up
i cleaned up your [ __ ] and i'm a bad
person
the truth hurts and you can see it in
kendall's face here he's processing the
reality that he isn't really a good
person he's only allowed to perceive
himself as good because his father has
covered up his crimes and he's so
superficial that he buys into the
public's perception of him as reality
logan perceives himself as all-knowing
which is why the final revelation of
this episode angers him so much because
he didn't see it coming he had thought
roman was capable and starting to prove
himself and he was but although he
wouldn't reveal his weakness to matson
in the previous scene now he just
accidentally sent it to logan making the
person he cares most about extremely
vulnerable just like his siblings roman
isn't used to facing the consequences of
his actions but now that the truth is
out just look at how uncomfortable he
seems with the reality of who he is and
what he does
he's just a scared child again like the
rest of them
that's what's so fascinating about the
writing in succession that although the
characters seem morally bereft we
occasionally get these glimpses into
their humanity beneath the surface
behind the web of lies they're all very
emotionally isolated damaged and empty
for the incredibly wealthy and powerful
the world is at your fingertips and you
can get away with creating your own
false reality filled with fake smiles
and a coercive sense of belonging and
support but for a family who own a media
empire that should be all about
separating fact from fiction they're all
far more comfortable living in the lie
hiding behind it because unfortunately
as we all know
nothing hurts more
than the truth
well you've made it this far so you
might as well like comment and subscribe
to help get this channel to the next
level
you